what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and we called it I
called it in the last video and you guys
called it down in the comments the
doctor had more tricks up his sleeve and
the heroes are about to enter a whole
world of hurt
as multiple deadly high and no mu are
released the epic war arc in boku no
hero continues with new twists around
every corner and I can't wait to talk
about it right here in this video if you
enjoyed the boku no hero content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
hitting the bell and then clicking off
the option that says oh if you don't do
that you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos
it's just how YouTube works you could
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest boku
no hero news and updates
finally this video will of course
include volca no hero manga spoilers
we're dealing with the latest crazy
twists in the story so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in the
aftermath of miracles smashing her way
into the secret lab and crushing poor
little Johnny and destroying much of the
lab itself
dr. Fujiko reminisces about his past he
fondly remembers johnny and all the
times Johnny had helped him poor Johnny
and he also thinks back to his
interactions with a younger all-4-one
all-4-one praises Fujiko saying that his
insatiable curiosity and inquisitive
nature had always been the source of his
strength all for one calls you Chico his
friend and thanks him from the bottom of
his heart this brief flashback reveals
that the two villains have a
relationship that goes beyond just a
business partnership they are clearly
close friends and they have a bond that
goes beyond self-interest
they have a genuine villain bromance
when she realizes that there is indeed
another doctor down in the lab miracle
reports this info to endeavor she also
reports that there are some very tough
looking nomal down in the lab miracle
wonders whether this doctor down here is
also a clone but she doesn't stress too
much about it because she knows that
she'll easily
able to find out if she kicks him hard
enough and ever tells miracle to catch
the doctor he'd like to tell her that
he'll be there to back her up but he is
also busy at the moment as we know and
ever and the other heroes are still
fighting a whole bunch of nomu upstairs
on the main floor of the hospital as
mandalay confirms that all the civilians
have now been evacuated from the
hospital the number six bro hero crust
makes his way down to the secret lab in
order to give back up to miracle for
those of you who might have forgotten
crust is also known as the shield heroes
so I wonder whether one of his sidekicks
is a raccoon girl anyway we still
haven't seen crusts quark in action but
based on the name shield hero crust we
can assume that it is a quark which
allows him to harden parts of his body
or create some sort of hard shield or
barrier during his trip down to the
secret lab crust uncovers secret
passageways inside the hospital which
suggests that the entire building was
designed by the villains specifically in
order to create the perfect hideaway for
them and for their noble and since these
passageways exist the villains can use
them to hide the Nommo and transport
them throughout the hospital without
being noticed this is why the nomal were
able to emerge seemingly out of nowhere
and attack the heroes as soon as they
entered the hospital meanwhile back
inside the secret lab miracle prepares
to find out whether this doctor Yuji Koh
is the real one her plan is to give him
a nice hard kick in the butt which again
confirms that miracle is the ideal waifu
because as i said in my last video
quoting my boy spike Spiegel I love a
woman who can kick my ass and miracle
literally does exactly that as for the
doctor he is unsure about what to do
next there are multiple high and nomu
there inside the lab with them but they
are not ready for primetime they are
still in the testing phase and even if
the doctor releases them now it will
take at least three hours for the Nomo
to stabilize the fact that all-4-one has
been indisposed has significantly slowed
the process of creating the high end
normal and the one high end no mood that
we have already seen hood was lost
during
against endeavor and hawks Dobby was
unable to recover it however despite
these complications the doctor doesn't
have a choice at this point
he must release the high end normal even
though they are not quite ready
otherwise he will be captured by the
heroes and his entire plan will be
ruined including his attempt to perfect
shigaraki miracle finally catches up to
the doctor and kicks his arm but the
doctor just dissolves into the same type
of liquid that twice his clothes
dissolve into once they've sustained
enough damage miracle turns and sees
another little gnome Oh similar to
Johnny hanging around the area where the
doctor clone had been the doctor refers
to this normal as mocha Chan and it
seems that this little normal was using
twice as quark to project a clone of the
doctor into reality once the clone
disappears miracle just kicks the crap
out of mocha Chan but that brief
distraction gives the real doctor enough
time to press a button a button which
activates the high and no mu Fujiko is
surprised that mocha Chan had used his
quirk in order to help the doctor
without being commanded to he did it on
his own in order to protect ug Co the
doctor proclaims that mochas courage
will not be in vain as he commands the
high-end nomu to destroy the hero
bastards as he says this the numerous
high end normal break through their
tubes and attack miracle rushing at her
and throwing her up against the wall it
is worth noting that as soon as they
emerge from the tubes these high ends
are able to speak they make several
statements about going wild going
berserk and killing the heroes it really
doesn't look good for me to call at this
point as at least five high and no mu
have her cornered these nomu have quite
an interesting appearance one of them
appears to be female with long hair a
tiara and breasts another one reminds me
of Super Buu from Dragon Ball Z with the
shape of his head and another one seems
to have the face of a mecha from
Evangelion interesting designs to be
sure and our girl miracle appears to be
in serious trouble here
don't forget just how much trouble one
high end no moo hood was able to cause
on its own here we have at least
five separate high-end nomal thankfully
crust makes it to the lab at this exact
time and he begins facing off against
one of the five normal crust appears to
be using his hardened arms to fight so
presumably his quark allows him to make
parts of his body such as his arms and
fists hard and/or sharp the gnomon that
crust his fighting is able to talk but
not only that it actually recognizes
crust and identifies him by name this
speaks to the fact that the intelligence
of these high-end nomal really is in a
totally different league from the
regular normal would you go then
apologizes to the normal for not being
able to give them more time and he asks
them to please handle this situation he
then uses his chair which can apparently
move through the building and carry the
doctor with it in order to escape while
the heroes are distracted by the high
ends the final panels show an injured
miracle smirking and saying that she's
just getting warmed up while at least
four of the high-end nomal are advancing
on her I called it in my last MHA video
and many of you guys also called it down
in the comments we knew that there would
be more doctor clones than just one
upstairs
and we knew that the villains still had
more tricks up their sleeve and of
course this chapter definitely confirmed
it however it is also clear that the
doctor did not want to use the high ends
at this point in time they were not
ready and he clearly used them only
because it was his last resort this
suggests that the doctor didn't intend
for the heroes to find his secret lab
even though the hospital itself appears
to be one big trap that includes secret
passageways full of normal it seems that
the doctor wasn't counting on the heroes
finding his secret lab so quickly for
that the heroes have to thank the
blueprints and Sue cauchy's agent who
infiltrated the hospital as an employee
and followed the doctor until he learned
where exactly the secret lab was located
the big question now is what happens
next miracle looks like she is in
serious trouble especially if the
strength of these nomu can be compared
to the strength of the previous high-end
nomu that we met which was hood hood
possessed multiple insanely powerful
quirks and he was far more intelligent
than normal
no mo he was able to cause a lot of
problems for multiple extremely strong
heroes including the top two Pro heroes
endeavor and Hawks so it's safe to say
that if these nomal are all as strongest
hood or if they are even stronger the
heroes could be in serious trouble we're
talking mass casualties among the heroes
but there is a key factor that we need
to take into consideration here we know
that these high-end nomu have been
activated before they were ready
Anuj Eco activated them reluctantly as a
last resort activating them so soon was
clearly not ideal for ug Co so does that
mean that activating them earlier has an
effect on how strong and capable these
nomu are does the fact that the nomal
were released before they were ready
mean that they are going to be weaker
than hood which would give the heroes a
better fighting chance or does the fact
that they were released earlier just
mean that they're going to be crazier
and harder to control but still just as
strong as they would have been otherwise
this is going to be a very important
question going forward don't forget that
there are at least 12 high end normal
including hood that doctor Fujiko has
created in previous chapters we clearly
saw that there were at least 12 tanks
holding 12 different high-end nomal
inside the lab so these five nomu that
we have seen so far could be just the
beginning of the heroes problems
not counting hood since he is gone there
should still be at least six other
high-end nomu that we haven't seen
emerge yet but that may have also been
activated along with the other five just
imagine eleven enemies who are on the
same level as hood or maybe even
stronger facing off against the heroes
that would be an absolute massacre for
the heroes the only hope that the heroes
have is that these No More going to be
weaker and more vulnerable than hood
because they were not ready when they
were activated this might be the key to
ultimate ly defeating them but we'll
have to wait and see the other big
question is what will happen to shigera
key now is Uchiko going to succeed in
escaping and taking shigaraki with him
or is she Guara key also going to have
to emerge
it's too early just like the high-end
nomal and if he does have to come out
early does this mean that he is going to
be vulnerable or is she got a key
already strong enough to pose a massive
threat to the heroes even before the
procedure has been completed there are
so many questions still left unanswered
after this chapter but at the same time
so many interesting things are happening
so many twists and turns so many doctor
clones and now these incredibly open Omo
are free and the heroes are in serious
trouble
I can't wait to see what happens next
please let me know what you guys think
are you loving this current arc as much
as I am and what do you think is going
to happen next
our shigaraki and the doctor going to
get away or as Shigure Aki going to have
to stop the procedure early and fight
the heroes also how strong are these
high-end Nomos going to be are they all
on the level of hood are they even
stronger or are they weaker because they
had to be activated early finally what
types of quirks and quirk combos do you
think that all of these crazy high and
nomal are going to have I am extremely
excited to see these Nomo in action
although I really don't want anything
bad to happen to rabbit waifu miracle so
having said that i am a bit conflicted
on that point I guess I'm hoping that
the Noma will showcase their epic
fighting skills on crust instead of
miracle but hey that's just me sorry
crust if you enjoyed this video and you
wanna see more boku no hero content on
the channel please leave a like to let
me know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications don't
forget that you have to go through the
trouble of actually hitting the bell and
selecting the option that says all if
you don't YouTube's gonna bury a lot of
our videos it's just the way it goes
feel free to hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making these videos
possible with all the problems
constantly facing YouTube patrons are
more important than ever thank you guys
so much
first up let me think are the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including Ingrid
Allen Adham the world Steelers the
school bus
Tyson query no and a quiet respect and
of course I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldred's Betty dolla beat Anatoly
kazansky alpha do on hell Cruz team
Sparky sixty-five cricket XP Rohan
Kapoor Jessica Maloney emperor otaku
Timothy Eve Argus Jean d'Arc Joe Stanton
JCC Wacha and John
Bunton if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]